what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with fall of X and Children of
the Vault now as always if you need to
get caught up you'll find a link to the
fall of X playlist at the end of this
video but the long and short of what's
going on is that while the main fall of
X event deals with orcus right the
anti-mutant government organization
tracking down the X-Men and all these
different mutants from across the world
and trying to kill them everywhere they
can there's a whole other plot taking
place here which is that a group called
The Children of the Vault basically
hyper evolved humans are essentially
Conquering the world and that's where
this picks up because cable and Bishop
right two mutants and all this rest on
their shoulders have basically figured
out what was going on and what they did
is they actually set a kind of event
unfolding where even orcas themselves
became aware of the children of the
Vault and in doing so it's kind of like
the enemy of my enemy is my friend and
so they're all basically attacking the
children of the vault at the same time
now what we're told here right squatting
on the surface of the Sun the
reconstructed orch mother mold births
1,000 Sentinel Sons an hour literally a
th000 Sentinels an hour these giant
mutant hunting robots right they're the
main body of the orcus Attack Force
inexhaustible Cavalry artillery and
infantry all in one from the reforge
these repurposed mutant murder machines
are sent directly to the city and tomoro
towns all over the planet tomorrow towns
basically being these towns that have
been taken over by the children of the
Vault and kind of operate like hubs for
those individuals who have been taken
over by the virus right and so what you
end up getting here is this guy who just
kind of shows up out of nowhere now this
is one of the guys from the children of
the Vault right from the city itself you
don't really see him all that often
right but like this dude is a mutant
who's just kind of shown up here right
one of the guys asks like what's your
name kid and he says it's a secret they
say it's bad that I should be ashamed
but I can't help it and when this guy
says stay back what are you holding like
what is that in your hand he says the
future do you want to see and he says mu
my name is Muerte right that means like
death murder what have you in Spanish he
basically blows up the entirety of the
orcus facility now for those of you guys
who have been following the fall of X
that's no small thing because it's quite
possible Marvel literally just ended the
entirety of the fall of X event in a
tie-in comic which is crazy not the
first time they've done it but it's kind
of a crazy thing at that point you
switch over to saraphina now the way it
works with the children of the vault in
the Here and Now is you've kind of got
like two individuals who were vying for
power within the children of the Vault
itself the first one is saraphina who
has more of like a diplomatic approach
to different situations right she thinks
things through the whole nine yards the
other one is capy tan he's a lot more
Reckless right he's more just like go in
guns blazing shoot first ask questions
later this calls for diplomacy and the
reason why is because cable right this
time trving mutant from the future with
just crazy Omega Level powers of
telepathy and even telekinesis has a gun
pointed at the city itself right the
main Hub the main frame if that thing
gets destroyed the entirety of the city
comes crashing down now why does that
matter because the nature of the
children of the vault is that with them
being hyper evolved it's done by the
city right like massive amounts of time
pass within the city itself technically
saraphina is thousands of years old even
though she's only ever been around for a
few years because when they go into the
Vault basically time passes differently
she can be killed she can be brought
back right and her powers can be
enhanced whatever weaknesses or whatever
it was that killed her before can
basically be neutralized in like the
newest version so she'll be immune to it
very similar to like Doomsday from DC
Comics is a really good example here but
the thing about this is that if that
City Mainframe gets destroyed
everything's done and gone and so what
you get is the statement from saraphina
where she says you're supposed to be a
mutant freedom fighter and now you work
with sapen supremacist I'm disappointed
and the response of cable is something
you'll learn about me I work with
whoever I have to even the Devil Himself
and where she asks but why they murdered
your entire race their genocidal Savages
his response is well that's why I wanted
to introduce you you've got so much in
common now that's one of the things to
understand is that cable as a guy right
this dude has seen some stuff right like
the war between himself and like Strife
basically is CL in the future right this
guy's lived through some really dark
times in the future he is Battle
hardened so someone like saraphina
popping up isn't really somebody that
he's going to like concern himself with
in the extreme he's more concerned about
like what the children are doing as a
whole as opposed to the individual
children themselves and so the result of
this is that Capitan shows up and
immediately starts trying to attack
cable now he does kind of get the upper
hand on him and he does get like a punch
and of course he is like holding him up
but again that's where like saraphina
and her diplomacy comes into play right
capy tan is you could Loosely call him a
Superman analog not necessarily not in
the exact same sense not like Hyperion
the century blue Marvel anybody along
those lines but he is incredibly capable
and the thing about this is that unlike
sarapo who wants to talk all this out
his response is like this world is ours
right it was promised to us like we are
going to take this planet over and
there's nothing you can do and the thing
about Cable's response here is that's
never going to happen right well of
course capy tan fire back and simply
says like it's over right orcus is
finished and the message has reached the
final stage ahead of schedule right all
these people who had been infected with
this quote unquote virus are people who
are now basically Servants of the
children of the Vault they're taking
over the planet has more or less been
successful there's seemingly nothing
that can be done to stop it now
philosophically you could actually see
where they're making a good case here
the whole idea behind the children of
the vault is to basically neutralize any
and all conflicts that exist out there
everybody's serving an operating under
one single ideology does it remove free
will sure but like Free Will in the
Marvel universe as it exists right now
are people Waging War against each other
how useful could free will possibly be
to the betterment of the human race in
Marvel so it's one of these things where
it's like getting rid of it may be the
best thing for Humanity because look
what they've done with it so far so it's
like it's it's really really cool right
it's a really cool concept and it
creates some really interesting
philosophical arguments right the whole
case that Capitan makes is he says it
will all be over soon things lose
finally shifting to coherent light the
world slows to a brilliant crawl in this
form she cannot imagine the darkness
everywhere she looks there is light she
allows the human sluggish projectiles to
pass harmlessly through her and Dives
deep into the dark pools of their eyes
burning up the optic nerves and turning
all 12 of their brains to Ash before
they can process the sight of her right
because she just moves that fast right
one of the members of the children of
the Vault that's the thing the children
of the Vault are ridiculously
overpowered so much so that that's why
cable and Bishop are doing what they're
doing the children of the Vault by
themselves in their current form would
be more than enough to dominate most all
of the human race and even all the X-Men
who were out there which is the reason
why their mission had to be one that was
covert and it had to be a mission of
subterfuge now fortunately for cable
who's almost done with all his living
thanks to the aggression of cap
Bishop shows up and saves him right and
when that happens the response of
saraphina is like Bishop cable what do
you hope to accomplish here the human
race has hours the mutant race is
already over and the response of kitan
is why is it so hard for you to
understand we are the future you can't
fight the future the response of cable
and Bishop is the best response ever
actually we're known for it right
because that's literally their thing
Bishop comes from a future where you
basically had Hope Summers who's not
overly important to this story but
basically instigated something called
like what was it like the 6sec war or
whatever it is where she like massacred
a million humans in like 6 seconds like
wiped them all out that jump started the
Sentinel program very similar to Days of
Future Past and then that led to the
mutant population and the human
population joining forces and throwing
the Sentinels off that M that he has on
his face that's the brand for mutants
that's how they determine who is a
mutant and who is a human cable we
already ran over his story so both of
these guys come from incredibly dark
Futures and their stories are like
trying to keep those futures from
happening so they're always fighting the
future that's their whole thing right
the response of of saraphina is you're
only delaying the inevitable and the
response of cable is more like stalling
for time but nurse Hy says it won't be
long now we're ahead of schedule two
right 3 2 1 and that's when the entirety
of the city just starts going haywire
right error codes and all kinds of stuff
what that does is it switches over to a
guy named Damon the living memory now
one of the things to know about this is
that this guy is quite literally a
living backup right a walking talking
computer system that holds all the
information about everything that
seemingly ever happened with the city
itself right the ultimate historian the
Future's Past personified 100,000 years
flow through his Crystal veins so he is
shocked to find for the first time
something new in the perfect lattice of
his body the guys in higher physical
form starts to mutate right it starts to
turn to machinery and what we end up
finding out and what cable had done is
that for those of you guys who are
curious Cable's arm is What's called the
technorganic virus that's one of the
reasons why you don't see him using his
telepathy and telekinesis all that often
because he's constantly using both of
those powers in conjunction to keep the
technorganic virus from eating him alive
if he wasn't able to do that he would
literally just be consumed by it it
would convert his cells to machinery and
he would die and that's always happening
100% of the time what he ended up doing
here right and what he says is he says a
thousand years in the future there's a
quiet little timeline where everything
is the failen and the failen is
everything as a younger less cautious
man I risked assimilation to get a
sample of the super strain of the Techno
organic virus that was used to convert
that Universe what does that mean one of
the things you guys may recall from the
beginning of this whole X-Men run not
even just the fall of X but going all
the way back to Jonathan Hickman's house
and powers of X the idea is that at some
point in the future the children of the
Vault would succeed in taking over the
world they would win and what they would
end up doing is actually merging with
humanity and that in doing so they would
create what was in effect a Babel Spire
because what that would do is it would
draw the attention of the failings
Covenant kind of like Marvel's
equivalent of the bore for those of you
guys who watch Star Wars but if you
don't basically they're just like living
Machinery but at that point in the
future when that future was written by
Hickman and the future that Cable's
talking about here they just travel the
cosmos and literally convert every
single planet out there that succeeded
in creating a Babel Spire which is
basically them just shouting out into
the ether hey we're ready to become part
of the failings Consciousness that's
effectively what it is when you make a
battle Spire unless it's Annihilation
Conquest then it's forced on you and
you're just converted into failinks or
you're integrated and converted into
food which is pretty wild here and so
what CA done is that in securing a small
sample of this he infected the entirety
of the city and he says I've been
keeping a sample of this under the X-Men
mansion Bishop picked it up a week ago
and what he says is like this gun is not
simply just a gun this thing is a
syringe the reality here is you've only
got a couple of options either you guys
can Retreat and you can deal with this
whole infection that's taking place in
your city because only 10% of it's
infected right now but if you don't if
you choose to continue fighting this
fight it will form a babble spire and it
will send a signal to the technarch
right a cobal world that feeds on solar
systems you'll destroy us and yourselves
in the process and it's a pretty smart
maneuver to make here and the reason why
is because if for no other reason than
self-preservation and the fact that the
children of the Vault do not have a
means to leave Earth and go to like
other planets that exist out there in
the universe
they basically say okay right we're
going to go back and we're going to do
our thing but what ends up happening is
the whole case that they make here is
like you think you've won the original
technorganic virus is in our database
the city is fighting your infection we
will develop a cure long before it can
generate a spire and so what they say is
here's the other part of this we figured
you guys would have something like this
so we took a second step we wired the
entirety of your birthing place right
where you basically create Offspring we
have wired that entire place with
Oblivion bombs I press this one button
and the entire generation that comes
after you all that genetic information
is gone all of you get wiped out now
cyan immediately goes to race in and
attack these guys but that's where
saraphina is like stop right and the
response is like what do you propose and
it's like leave take your message and
your city and return to the Vault never
come back here and so it's one of those
things where like they don't really have
a choice because as all this is going
down and that's where capitan's like
you're bluffing right like you're not
going to kill a world just to defeat us
but that's where saraphina is like no
yeah he's definitely right there's no
way the X-Men would do something like
this and the response of Bishop is X-Men
no no no the X-Men were pushing into a
meat grinder my friend there are no
X-Men anymore there's just two old
Soldiers with nothing to lose so what do
you think's going to happen here do you
really believe that we won't kill a
world to stop you do you really believe
believe that's not going to happen
because if you do keep fighting the good
fight and we'll all go out in a blaze of
glory but if there's one part of you
that really wants to survive here then
do what we tell you to and that's
exactly what happens the children of the
Vault race back to the Vault itself they
effectively Retreat right it's like we
cannot risk the future that cannot
happen they retreat they shut down the
message all everybody out there who was
infected they all go back to normal
Humanity just kind of returns to a
regular state but something to
understand here this is is not the end
of the children of the Vault because
saraphina before they leave she gives
them a parting word she says Capitan was
right I see I was too gentle too
magnanimous in this Incarnation I
suspect I won't be in the future we
could have save them you know something
Unthinkable is coming I've seen it we
could have saved all of humanity and
even you the response of Bishop is we'll
take our chances the city ultimately
folds up and it returns back to the
Vault and everything goes goes back to
what passes for normal in the Marvel
Universe but that's one of the things to
know here is the children of the Vault
were the good guys in this story they
were going to save humanity and they
were going to save what was left of the
mutant population because if you guys
have been paying attention to the news
in Marvel what is coming is very dark
and very Bleak and by the time that hits
the X-Men Humanity they will pray for
death before the end but with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end if you guys need to get up on
follow X make sure you click this link
to the playlist and I will catch you all
later peace